Lately, more and more variants are emerging in various places around the world.
So, why are they showing up now?
And what does this mean for the pandemic?
Viruses are very simple.
They're basically just a shell of protein surrounding some genetic material:...
...either DNA or RNA.
That genetic material is made up of molecules...
...that can be represented as a series of letters, like this.
Each part of this code contains instructions for how to make one specific protein...
...that allows the virus to function.
A virus has one goal: to make more of itself.
But because it's so simple, it can't do that on its own.
So, it uses you.
Every time a virus infects a person, it uses their cells to make copies of itself...
...replicating this complex code again, and again, and again.
But eventually, it makes a mistake.
Sometimes, it deletes or adds a letter.
Sometimes it flips them around.
That mistake is called a mutation,...
...and it slightly changes the instructions for making the virus.
That slightly altered virus is a variant.